julien clerc jeudi soir vous serez sur
la scène de l'olympia entraîne sont
aimés mais je sais que vous penserez à
tous ceux qui souffrent du sida
je participerai aussi à la soirée donc
je voyais en sortant de scène en sortant
de scène j'irai sur le plateau je
chantais vous viendrez bien sûr bien sûr
en chanter et que pensez vous de cette
de cette angoisse des jeunes aujourd'hui
diffuse à cause du sida ou à cause de
plein d'autres choses il ya beaucoup de
choses qui peuvent les des angoisses et
je crois évidemment cette cette maladie
terrible
et puis aussi raisonnablement c'est le
problème de leur avenir dans une société
qui a changé très très très rapidement
en un siècle beaucoup plus rapidement
que le monde a changé beaucoup plus
rapidement d'insectes qui n'a changé ou
pendant pendant les siècles qui ont
précédé les antifas tous alors je
voudrais qu'on écoute un extrait de
l'une de vos nouvelles chansons que vous
chanterez demain soir à l'olympia
balade en blanc en blanc
les rois du ciel sur
tha
qui passe d'armes
en s'interdisant
l'échec du prix de
dumont
en blanc
à
mais trahison
les ardue
blanc
le schatz
c'est quoi c'est un hymne à l'amour à la
paix cette chanson sûrement oui c'est
tout si jenson sûr nous apprend depuis
toujours que le blanc est là la couleur
de la pureté et la chanson traite de
sale blanc n'est peut-être pas la
perfection qu'on dit la fin de la
chanson je le dis sans avoir écouté il
ya des soirs on envie d'être en noir
être un peu noir voilà pourquoi mon
amour il fait bon certains soirs d'être
un peu noir vous avez chanté très
récemment à l'olympia triomphe et vous
revenez sur la scène demain pourquoi je
crois parce qu'il y avait beaucoup de
gens qui n'avaient pas pu assister au
spectacle
donc on remet on remet un coup je sais
c'est complet de semaine je le crois
donc pourquoi pas nouveau bercy la
dernière fois en cinq ans non mais non
là il y avait un choix de persister en
81 5 je crois non il ya eu un choix réel
deux salles différentes de salles plus
petites qui répond je crois eu une
attente générale du public de voir les
arts les artistes d'un peu plus près ils
ont peut-être les gens sont un peu lassé
de ces de ces grands-messes ait envie de
revoir dans des endroits plus plus
humain peut-être les artistes un peu
plus près je crois que vous avez écrit
ou jouer ou chanter 220 chanson écrit
avec d'autres évidemment été la musique
25 ans de carrière et pourtant vous
traversez comme ça tout
toutes ces notes toutes ces rumeurs
qu'on fait de vous ce cas est-ce qu'il
ya un sucre et julien clerc bon j'ai
passé un secret ce que je fais c'est que
je suis strictement dans la même le même
état d'esprit que j'étais quand j'ai
commencé j'avais 20 ans c'est à dire que
ce qui m'intéressait dans la vie c'est
d'être le fer des mélodies assis un
piano et d'essayer de mettre dessus des
paroles qui se tiennent qui touche le
coeur des gens soient des chansons
d'amour soit d'autre chose qui
sensibilise les gens diront nous et et
que c'est ce que je sais faire et ce que
j'aime faire et de d'essayer de bien de
bien les chanter je vous savez dans le
spectacle je lis un extrait de
ben d'un livre qui était clos début du
siècle par yvette guilbert qui est une
chanteuse très célèbre en france et
l'extrait que je lis je trouve est un
très bon résumé finalement 2-2 drôle
enfin où il peut être du rôle les
artistes dans la société
l'extrait dit à peu près je le raccourci
hilliard h on nous a l'argent à
l'étroitesse de la pensée libérons-nous
de tout ce qui n'est pas l'enfantement
de la beauté le travail sera notre luxe
j'ai la chance énorme de faire c'est
vrai je crois un travail qui était un
luxe depuis depuis 25 ans ce n'est pas
je crois de donner à tout le monde de
faire sage
j'ai de la chance et j'ai de la chance
de pouvoir véhiculer des choses qui est
de pouvoir toucher le coeur des gens en
même temps le point jolis mots quand ils
vous présentent il parle de vous clair
obscur vous êtes présent très présent
vous voit on vous entend chanter on vous
apprécié et pourtant vous réussissez à
vous protéger vous faites ça comment et
comment ne sais pas je suis comme ça je
crois que c'est un métier public on se
doit aux gens mais on se doit surtout
d'être enfin c'est peut-être un poncif
sujet d'hier on se doit d'être comme on
est de montrer son vrai visage aux gens
et aussi on est dans la ville si on a
certes un côté ludique si on n'aime pas
montrer même à des gens qu'on connaît
certaines choses il n'y a pas de raison
de ne pas transporter sa aussi sur le
monsieur muscle dans votre métier donc
j'essaie d'être le plus de plus possible
comme je suis on est bien restez comme
vous êtes et comme ça merci julien clerc
et l'on terminera ce journal par un
reportage d'eric